we begin in Ukraine where fresh
explosions have hit the capital Kiev
President Vladimir solenski says Russia
used so-called Kamikaze drones to attack
the city keeps mayor says residential
buildings have been damaged and he urged
people to take shelter the explosions
come one week after Moscow launched
large-scale airstrikes across Ukraine
and despite President Vladimir Putin
since saying he has no plans for further
attacks of that kind
Let's cross over now to our
correspondent in Kiev funny your day
along with many people in Ukraine
started with explosions tell us more
now the current situation gives City the
air raid alert is no longer in effect
but in many other regions across the
country it is so of course people are
bracing unfortunately for more
indiscriminate attacks or shelling what
we know currently there's no report or
no number whether casualties are to uh
whether there are any casualties here in
Cave City but we know from the city May
here from Kim Smith Mr Klitschko that at
least two people are trapped in those
rubbles underneath damaged buildings
what about 18 could be rescued so far
with emergency workers on the side this
is all happening in this District where
I'm staying right now if you do not know
exactly what was uh the exact designated
Target to say so but the official
information here from the Ukrainian
sources is that apparently critical
infrastructure was attacked now you have
to know that there is a heating plant
here in the Kiev city and what I can
just basically tell you is what I have
seen this this morning this morning what
I've heard and at first I've heard
shortly after a 6 30 a very loud sound
of what turned out was a drone literally
I thought the Drone is coming straight
into a hotel this is how close it was
and literally right after an explosion
followed by several other explosions the
air raid alert as I say is currently not
in effect but does it say that people
feel safe certainly not they're bracing
format for more attacks and are asking
themselves why again why again the heart
of Kiev and why is this happening yeah
the Russians tried taking Kiev and
failed at the very beginning of this war
um do you think the Russians are now uh
is this a new Focus perhaps in in this
war against Ukraine
without getting into much speculation
but certainly if you attack the capital
of any country this is quite symbolic
for uh in this case for Russia of course
they want to show that they do have the
upper hand in this war that they uh
because of the very successful
counter-offensive by Ukraine seem to
have lost quite a bit here whether this
is happening because there were attacks
in Belgrade which is a town in Russia
close to the Ukrainian Buddha or whether
this is happening because there was an
attack on Donetsk which also Russia
blames Ukraine of having uh conducted we
do not know but alone the fact is for
the very for the second time after one
week again the very same district of key
of cities being had hit is not only a
wake-up call to so many people here in
Ukraine that no longer you can have the
feeling of safety that you used to have
at least for the past couple of months
here in Kiev City that you're relatively
safe here but it's certainly and this is
what the Ukrainian government is trying
to urge leaders foreign leaders to it is
also wake up colos should be understood
as such for international leaders to
support Ukraine with air defense Systems
Prior to all of these attacks Mr
zelenski pointed out he only has quote
about 10 percent of what it needs to to
defend the air and by that defending the
citizens of Ukraine and obviously if
that's true that's not a very very a big
number Ben
what about the residents of Kiev I mean
should they be staying there or is there
any way to prepare for something like
this
including us everybody's basically
prepared with a backpack of things that
you may just grab and and go because you
do not know where you're going to end up
in the next couple of hours the next
couple of days so you can prepare in the
sense that you're putting your your
essential items into into your backpack
but can you really prepare when this is
happening during the night while you're
sleeping certainly not and this is
exactly what's quite perfidious about
this these attacks be missile attacks or
the drones uh that that really work as
Kamikaze drones a so-called suicide
drones that simply just drop on a Target
there's no way you can leave literally
you have like seconds to get up from
your bed and can count yourself and
consider yourself lucky if your
Residential Building is not being hit
DW's funny fat chat thank you very much
for the reporting
well Ukraine says many of Russia's
recent attacks have used iranian-made
drones Tehran denies selling drones to
Russia but analysts see evidence of
Iranian instructors training Russian
soldiers to use them here's a look at
what the unmanned tools of War are and
what Russia is doing with them
they call it the moped for its loud
crude mechanical noise that can be heard
from far away the Iran made Shahid 136
drone here seen hovering over Odessa
but it's no joke these drones can have
devastating effects
though Iran denies selling them to
Russia Kiev says fragments of this drone
shot down in southern Ukraine have
Iranian as well as Russian markings
the Shah head is a series of drones made
by Iran the 136 has a wingspan of two
and a half meters and Carries 40
kilograms of explosives
it's classified as a loitering munition
it can hang out for hours in the air
until a Target is found then it zooms in
becoming a missile that destroys itself
on impact
what makes Iranian drones useful to
Russia is that they are cheap the shot
had 136 costs about 20 000 Euros each
other
Russia flies them alone or in low
altitude swarms hoping that one or two
will get through Ukrainian air defenses
which have trouble seeing them although
several have been shot down
[Music]
Ukraine is still figuring out how to
deal with the threat they pose
but they will have to act fast president
zielinski claims that Russia has ordered
more than 2 000 of the shahids
the more we can speak to Mike Martin the
former British army officer and a war
studies fellow at King's College London
nice to see you again Mike
um Russia's repeatedly used drones in
recent weeks especially and has
reportedly ordered thousands more as we
heard there how effective are drones
compared to other forms of attack
well the beauty of drones unmanned
aerial Vehicles is that they don't have
people on board
um they're much cheaper and so you can
send larger numbers of them at the same
time and what that does is that
overloads air defense systems um as I
think you hinted at in your package and
that's why they can be very effective
the Kamikaze ones of course can only be
used once
um but Russia's resorting more and more
to drones by the sounds of it
um has it run out of other weapons
uh certainly it has um one effect that
the sanctions have had on Russia is
they've been unable to import uh
high-tech things like gyroscopes that
you need for precision guided Munitions
and so
um we've heard rumors about them getting
artillery shells from the North Koreans
and now they're buying uh drones and
other weapons from the Iranians
um this is basically to replenish the
stockpiles that they've used up already
in the war
Kiev and Washington are both accused
state run of supplying drones to Russia
and the eu's top Diplomat said today the
block is seeking concrete evidence for
any Iranian involvement in the war but
Iran consistently denies this is there
any doubt that these drones come from
Iran
uh no I'd say it's a sort of 98 99
certain and not just drones as well
um we've seen evidence of uh missiles
that are being used in the conflict that
have also come from Iran and you know
Iran is is quite a competent weapons
manufacturer of low-tech what you might
call Value Weaponry uh and and so it's
fairly natural that Russia might go to
Iran and these These are cheap plentiful
weapons
so how much of a helping hand is Iran
giving Russia
well what I think is the most
interesting thing is traditionally
Russia has supplied weapons to Iran but
here what we're seeing is the opposite
of that so I think that tells us
um the weakness of Russia's position
um I think that really what this is is
it it enables Russia to continue
fighting albeit with slightly different
weapon systems but it enables it to
continue fighting the provision of you
know these Kamikaze Jones the Shaheed or
even some missile systems is not going
to change the Strategic balance of the
war
Mike Martin from King's College London
thank you so much for the analysis thank
you thank you